the mission of Miller's Technology  Transfer team is to help develop the AI  ecosystem in Quebec and Canada this is  mainly done in two different ways first  we work closely with companies to help  them innovate by introducing AI in their  stack or improving their existing AI  solutions second we build machine  learning training programs to help  prepare a new generation of machine  learning experts who can contribute to  industrial projects apart from those  mandates team members dedicate 20% of  their time to work on their own research  projects with members of the academic  and industrial communities if you're  passionate about machine learning and  deep learning and if you care about  having an impact on industrial projects  and all sectors of the economy come and  join us  we're hiring